un forum dédié aux droits de l'homme
dont la présidence vient d'être confié à
l'Iran pays lui-même accusé de
répression sur son peuple c'est la
dernière polémique qui touche
l'Organisation des Nations Unies cette
institution est-elle une véritable force
unificatrice ou un machin comme disait
de Gaul né le 24 octobre 1945 au
lendemain de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
l'ONU s'est fixé quatre objectifs dont
les principaux sont le maintien de la
paix et de la sécurité dans le monde et
le développement des relations
coopératives et amicales entre les
nations pour se faire l'ONU compte six
organes il y a d'abord un conseil de
tutelle mais qui n'est plus actif depuis
la fin de la décolonisation il y a aussi
un conseil économique et sociale une
cour internationale de justice un
secrétariat qui gère l'organisation dans
son quotidien avec à sa tête un
secrétaire général en l'occurrence
Antonio guterz il y a aussi une
assemblée générale où 193 États dans le
monde disposent d'un siège et enfin un
Conseil de sécurité arrêtons-nous sur ce
daning car lui seul est apte à prendre
des résolutions comme des positions des
recommandations des sanctions
économiques ou encore des opérations
militaires il est composé de 15 membres
10 sont élus par l'assemblée générale
pour 2 ans et 5in sont permanents ces
cinql sont les vainqueurs de la la
Seconde Guerre mondiale à savoir la
Russie la Chine la France le Royaume-Uni
et les États-Unis et c'est là
qu'intervient la première d'une longue
liste de critiques adressé à l'ONU car
ces permanences de cinq États jugé trop
peu pour certains et ce droit de vetto
entraîne des situations parfois
hubuesques par exemple en 2003 lorsque
les États-Unis ont bloqué la
condamnation de leur invasion en Irak ou
plus récemment lorsque la Russie a
neutralisé toute tentative de
condamnation de son opération militaire
en Ukraine conséquence le Conseil de
sécurité n'a adopté aucune résolution
concernant l'Ukraine effectivement on
imagine mal un état saautocondamné et
depuis 1946 la Russie a dégainé 143 fois
son droit de vetto contre 86 pour les
États-Unis 30 pour la Grande-Bretagne et
seulement 18 pour la France et la Chine
la question des financements aussi pose
problème en effet de nombreux États se
montrent réticents à s'acquité de leur
contribution au budget régulier alors
même que ce sont ces contributions
obligatoires qui permettent le
fonctionnement de l'organisation un
fonctionnement estimé à plus de 3
milliards d'euros autre critique celle
qui avance l'impuissance des casques
bleus échec de la prévention et de la
protection lors du génocide rwandais en
1994 incapacité à prévenir les conflits
en ex-yugoslavie au début des années 90
mauvaise coordination de l'aide
humanitaire après le séisme en Haïti en
2010 autant d'actes manqués pour la
force militaire de maintien de la paix
de l'ONU et de nombreux observateurs
voient dans les raisons de cet
immobilisme les nominations de personnes
non compétentes ou les copinages avec
des pays enfraignant les droits de
l'homme enfin certains reprochent à
l'ONU son caractère politique car oui
l'ONU reste un enjeu de pouvoir et
d'influence les grandes puissances se
disputent contrôle des comités les états
tentent d'influencer l'examen de
certaines résolutions et le tout avec
différentes visions du monde qui
s'affrontent exemple récent avec Israël
et le Hamas après 15 jours de
négociation raté en Conseil de sécurité
à cause des véaux notammentx Américains
à les indéfectibles des Israéliens
l'assemblée général a fini par s'emparer
du sujet et a voté le 27 octobre dernier
un appel à une trêve humanitaire
immédiate dans la région sans mentionner
le Hamas ni condamner explicitement
l'attaque du 7 octobre cet appel n'est
pas contraignant car l'assemblée
générale n'a pas ce pouvoir en revanche
celui de prendre le cou de la communauté
internationale et de soulever les
boucliers en l'occurrence des
représentants israéliens alors l'ONU
at-elle encore un avenir du propre
d'Antonio
gter plus aucune efficacité en réalité
c'est devenu une caisse de résonance des
problèmes mondiaux donc on voit on
arrive à une à une paralysie et à une
inefficacité en fait il se passe plus
rien toutes les réformes en fait
deviennent très très compliquées parce
que c'est des sujets éminemment
politique et on voit que pour pour toute
réforme l'ONU est devenu le lieu de
l'affrontement global entre le sud et
les pays qui sont les moteurs de ce Sud
global comme la Chine et l'Inde par
exemple et les Occidentaux la Chine
notamment essaie de s'infiltrer dans
toutes les institution de l'ONU parce
que elle veut changer la façon dont le
monde est gouverné ce qui risque de se
passer c'est qu' de plus en plus de pays
vont se détourner de l'ONU et la laisser
dans un état moribon en réalité on le
voit déjà à l'assemblée générale de
l'UNU cette année qui est le grand raout
annuel et qui avant était un événement
mondial on voit que cette année Emmanuel
Macron par exemple ne s'y est pas rendu
il y a une sorte de de d'abandon de plus
en plus manifeste un jour l'ONU
deviendra totalement obsolète si elle
n'est pas capable de se
[Musique]
réformer